the u.s. jails more people than any
other country and it's one of only two
countries that has a for-profit bail
system what does that mean well the
system works like this say you're
arrested for allegedly committing a
crime one of three things will happen
you get released until your trial you're
denied bail and sit behind bars until
trial or you're offered bail an amount
of money that you have to pay to get out
of jail until trial it's like the courts
insurance policy that you don't skip
town once you show up to trial you get
that money back paying bail allows you
to go back to your kids your job while
awaiting trial but what if you can't pay
that bond it is an explicitly class and
wealth based discriminatory process for
determining who gets to be free while
they await trial and who is forced to
remain incarcerated while they maintain
their innocence so while a rich man
charged with murder can afford his
250,000 dollar bail
someone arrested for shoplifting who
can't pay their $500 bail may sit behind
bars for months before their trial date
at any given time in the u.s. there are
nearly 450,000 people locked up awaiting
trial including both those denied bail
and those unable to pay there is another
option
if your bail is set at save seventy
thousand dollars but you don't have the
money you can pay a local bondsman to
cover the fee for you but here's the
catch bondsman take 10 percent so while
the court will return the 70 thousand
dollars when you get to trial
you still owe that bondsman seven
thousand dollars that amount will
accumulate interest until you can pay it
back and bonds companies are allowed to
take extreme measures including breaking
into your home to collect their payments
it's a really lucrative industry with
serious consequences for those who can't
pay I was arguing a motion to get one of
my clients out of jail
the bail was set at $100,000 well above
his ability to pay because he couldn't
pay the bail and because
the judge refused to release him without
bail he pled guilty pleading guilty can
get you a plea bargain down to a penalty
of say community service while the
offense would be on your record guilty
or not you wouldn't necessarily have to
do time because doing time is the last
thing you want in jail you risk not just
losing your job in relationships but
also the possibility of sexual assault
physical violence and contracting a
contagious disease and to ask somebody
to endure that for more than a month
simply because they're too poor to pay
bail undermines the integrity of the
entire criminal justice system the u.s.
bill of rights bans what's called
excessive bail but even relatively low
bail amounts say $500 or $5,000 can be
considered excessive to some and it can
mean the difference between life and
death take the case of Sandra bland who
was arrested in Texas for allegedly
assaulting a police officer after a
minor traffic violation the court set
Bland's bond at five thousand dollars
she couldn't pay so she was forced to
stay in jail three days later she was
found dead in her cell the for-profit
bail system is problematic but there are
alternatives Kentucky became the first
of four states to ban commercial bail in
1976 and 94% of felony defendants there
still show up for trial so if other
systems are working should the large
majority of states continue to use
for-profit bail
you